If you think back to the table
views we've built so
far, Bond villains, make your
own adventure, favorite things.
They all had an array of data that
they used to populate a table.
For meme, we're going to have two
view controllers displaying memes.
A collection and a table.
They could each have their
own separate array of memes.
But that doesn't seem right.
The two ViewControllers should
be accessing the same data using
a shared model.
So where can one keep a data model so
that it can be accessed
by both ViewControllers?
The AppDelegate, the delegate
to the UIApplication object,
is a good place because it can be
accessed from anywhere in your project.
Now keeping data in the App delegate
is a little bit controversial.
But in our case,
it's the simplest option.
And there are solid precedents for it,
including Xcode's core data templates.
You can add your memes array to
the App Delegate with this line of code.
And whenever you create a meme,
you'll want to add it to
the app delegates array.
So you could add the following code in
the view controller that edits the meme.
And finally, when you want to access
this data from the collection view
controller or the table view controller,
you could add these lines.
For a recap of the code in these three
methods, see the upcoming text note.